>>Steven: A lot of people think that
Project Based Learning is fluff.
So what we did, instead of having
a three-column rubric that has
"Unsatisfactory, Proficient and
Advanced," we added a fourth column.
It is the "Standards,"
what has to be taught.
>>Peggy: Students are going to
address the content that they need
to learn through this PBL approach.
PBL provides the meat
of the curriculum.
It's not a side thing you do
at the end of the unit for fun.
It's really how you're engaging
students in that content learning.
>>Lisa: I start with
the standards in mind.
It's called "Backwards Design."
And so you start with the standards,
you start with what the
final exam would look like.
Again, we still do have final
exams, and unit exams at the end
of each topic that we're learning,
because they need that practice.
And so I make the test ahead
of time, and then I plan all
of the appropriate activities that
we're going to do for the project.
>>Steven: Our students
still take assessments,
district assessments, and benchmarks.
We still have that
accountability factor.
And when our students
then perform very well
on those, it shows it works.
>>Peggy: There's really
two main reasons
that a teacher should
use a PBL approach.
And one is that the students
will learn disciplinary content.
I mean, that's critical.
But the second equally
important reason to use it is
that students develop critical
thinking skills while they're
learning the content.
They learn to collaborate
with others.
They have the opportunity to be
creative in the way they think
about the problem, and
then to put their own spin
on their solution to the problem.
>>Steven: It's a shift in
the delivery of instruction.
Students at this school
not only get the knowledge,
but they learn the application.
So the knowledge then becomes
relevant when they have to apply it
to a real-world situation.